fueron richard burt fue también para mí
fue en esas que durante los ataques del
6 de enero se dice que estaba en la casa
blanca con el expresidente donald trump
fue mitt romney de yuta que se esperaba
que votará en contra mitt romney fue ex
candidato a la presidencia y fue un
abierto opositor en el partido
republicano del ex presidente don ottón
durante sus últimos cuatro años de
administración también está lisa
murkowski senadora de atlanta también
opositora a donald trump a pesar de ser
republicana y casi de luisiana él fue el
era una voto bisagra que los
republicanos estaban tratando de
convencer de que votará en contra de el
impeachment pero lo hizo a favor sin
embargo usted lo mencionaba bien fueron
57 votos a favor del impeachment 43 en
contra es decir no se logran los 67 que
se esperaban por una diferencia de 10
votos y donald trump es absuelto